[Music]
why are people pausing the lord of the
rings to watch someone break a toe or
get their finger bitten off
keep watching to find out
as the town that serves as home to frodo
and bilbo baggins hobbiton is the
quintessential ideal of a quiet locale
where any hobbit would love to live
author j.r.r tolkien based the fictional
village on the beauty and tranquility of
the english countryside and it's where
the tale truly begins
the description of hobbiton in the
novels not only gives readers a sense of
what life is like for a hobbit but has
made generations of fans yearn for their
own cozy little hobbit hole
peter jackson a super fan of the novels
and the rest of the lord of the rings
crew knew they had to find the perfect
location to film the hobbiton scenes and
they found what they were looking for in
new zealand according to the hobbiton
tours website a 1 250 acre farm would
eventually become the shire the website
also states that it took over nine
months of construction to build the
hobbit village with the film crew
actually receiving help from the new
zealand army the result of the
filmmaker's hard work paid off in the
final cut of the film at the beginning
of the fellowship of the ring we see
frodo and gandalf riding in a carriage
down the pastoral streets of hobbiton
and for those who've read the books it
feels like the pages of the novels come
to life in 2002 guided tours were made
available for anyone to come and visit
the set and after jackson rebuilt the
set in 2009 for the hobbit the site
became a permanent tourist destination
after his unforgettable 111th birthday
celebration bilbo makes preparations to
leave hobbiton for good although it
proves to be an immense struggle for him
bilbo manages to leave the one ring
behind with frodo along with most of his
belongings and the deed to his home bag
end at gandalf's direction frodo keeps
the ring secret and safe even though he
has no idea of the true power it holds
gandalf having his suspicions leaves the
shire to find out what he can about
bilbo's mysterious ring
when he returns he is haggard and
disturbed not the common collected
wizard he once was
frodo hands over the ring only to be
surprised by gandalf throwing it into
the fireplace
what follows is perhaps one of the most
recognizable shots in the trilogy
gandalf takes the ring out of the fire
and places it in frodo's hand assuring
the hobbit that it is quite cool
moments later writing appears across the
band which gandalf ominously translates
for frodo and the audience
[Music]
not only is this phrase insanely
quotable but it establishes what will
become the central plot of the series
the one ring of power is an evil
artifact that must be destroyed at all
costs and poor frodo is the one to do it
although gandalf hates sending his
hobbit friend on such a dangerous errand
he hopes that frodo's bravery and
loyalty will get the job done
as frodo begins his journey out of the
shire he is joined by his loyal friend
samweis gamji and later by the
mischievous duo pippen tuk and mary
brandy buck mary and pippin literally
bump into sam and frodo while on the run
from the crotchety farmer maggot after
stealing some of his prized vegetables
after the four hobbits tumble down a
hill they gather themselves to their
feet just as frodo senses a dangerous
presence coming down the road frodo
frantically commands the others to hide
and they find the perfect spot under the
roots of a large tree the scene is one
of the most suspenseful moments in the
movie with the four hobbits huddled
together in a dank hole teeming with
creepy crawlies as the terrifying figure
of the hooded dark rider one of the
dreaded ring wraiths approaches as the
ringwraith sniffs out his unseen prey
frodo almost gives into temptation and
nearly puts on the one ring luckily for
our heroes the writer is distracted and
passes without discovering their hiding
place it's a wake up call for the
hobbits that there are great dangers
waiting for them outside the shire
although tolkien's work is held in high
esteem the unfortunate truth is there is
a sad lack of female presence in his
novels to make up for this the writers
of the lord of the rings film trilogy
expanded the role of an underutilized
character from the novels arwen evenstar
the writers gave arwen a much larger
part in the films sometimes adding her
into scenes from which she was absent in
the books in the fellowship of the ring
the hobbit's harrowing ordeal on
weathertop results in frodo being
stabbed by a morgle blade which if left
untreated will turn frodo into a shadow
of himself not unlike the ringwraiths
luckily arwen comes upon the group and
insists on taking frodo to her father
elrond to get healed before it's too
late
what follows is a tension-fueled chase
scene with arwen riding as fast as she
can with frodo in tow and the nas ghoul
hot on their heels the chase comes to a
climax when arwen and frodo cross the
river that forms the border of the elven
lands in a show of great courage arwen
challenges the writers
if you want him come and claim him
it's tough not to be impressed by
arwen's heroism in that moment
especially for a character who is
essentially wasted in the original
novels she then conjures up a great wave
to wash away the enemies this scene is
truly memorable not only for the
impressive special effects but also for
the way it establishes arwin's character
in the films
one does not simply re-watch the council
of elrond scene in the fellowship of the
ring without pausing at the exact moment
that boromir makes his iconic pose
you know the one he's looking very
serious and holding up his hand with his
fingers forming a circle indicating the
eye of sauron meanwhile the audience is
picturing their own fill in the blank
text superimposed over the image in the
slim chance that you are in the dark on
this one the one does not simply mean
was a popular fad that spammed the
internet for several years starting in
2004 in which someone would start a
phrase with one does not simply and then
finish the thought accordingly
it's also refreshing to note that the
actor himself sean bean is very aware of
the meme and finds it quite amusing
in fact he once told radio times
magazine that he thinks the memes
featuring his face will be his quote
unintended legacy and he seems to be
totally on board with it
as the wizard to end all wizards gandalf
the grey is the epitome of wisdom power
and kindness he acts as a guide and
mentor to those who follow him yet he is
also a loyal friend and a fearsome
fighter that any good guy is lucky to
have on their side perhaps the most
spectacular scene in the fellowship of
the ring is gandalf's face-off against
the balrog in the minds of morya not
only are the special effects for the
creature itself awe-inspiring but we get
to see gandalf looking like an
incredible badass
[Music]
just as we cheer for gandalf while he
holds back the monstrous foe so we weep
for him when he falls into the depths
below no one can forget the image of
gandalf clinging to the edge of the rock
before his final counsel for the
fellowship fly you fools
even those who knew gandalf would return
in the second film couldn't help but
feel something akin to grief at his loss
for the ones for whom gandalf's fall
came as a complete surprise you probably
had to press pause on your remote to ask
yourself what the heck just happened
though he mostly appears in the first
film of the lord of the rings trilogy
the character of boromir had a
surprising impact on the series as a
whole
part of that is likely due to the superb
performance of actor sean bean yet it
can also be attributed to the writing
team's careful consideration of the
character's development it could easily
be misconstrued that boromir is a bad
guy when in fact he is much more complex
than that in truth he is a man desperate
to save his people and that desperation
is a weakness that the one ring seeks to
exploit when boromir tries to take the
ring from frodo by force in the third
act of the fellowship of the ring he
immediately recognizes his error and
attempts to compensate by doing what he
was meant to do protect the innocent
sadly boromir finds death in a hail of
arrows while defending marion pippin
during an attack with his dying words he
confesses his faults to aragorn while
pledging his final allegiance to the
true king of gondor the heartbreaking
scene is enough to bring a tear to
anyone's eye and might have you reaching
for the pause button so you can compose
yourself
[Music]
in the two towers aragorn legolas and
gimli are tracking a pack of orcs who
have kidnapped their friends mary and
pippen during their search they come
upon a group of soldiers led by ayamur
ayamer informs the trio that he and his
soldiers recently ambushed a group of
orcs but left no survivors
when aragorn and the others find the
remains of the orc horde they find no
trace of their hobbit companions
believing the halflings may be dead
aragorn lashes out by kicking a nearby
orc helmet and screaming as he falls to
his knees
while the kick was in the script the
scream was not and that's because actor
viggo mortensen broke his toe in that
take
yet instead of asking for the director
to cut mortensen used his physical pain
to express the torment his character was
feeling in the moment talk about method
acting
one of the most beloved characters in
the trilogy gollum is a creature somehow
both detestable and highly sympathetic
after being in possession of the one
ring for many years the hobbit like
being once known as smeagle has become
an emaciated husk who lives only to hold
his precious once more under layers of
hatred and greed though there is still
the person who was once smeagle and
frodo's compassion allows smeagle to
appear through the cracks where gollum
is suspicious and filled with rancor
smeagle is trusting and eager to please
in one of the most memorable golem
scenes we see the two sides of the
character arguing with one another as if
they were two separate personalities and
indeed in many ways they are
the scene was shot brilliantly by
director jackson in a two-camera setup
with motion capture performer andy
circus giving a magnificent depiction of
the dual nature of the character the
audience really feels as if they are
seeing a conversation between two people
and it's a scene worth pausing to take
in the sheer genius of it all
the monumental battle of helm's deep is
inarguably the highlight of the two
towers taking up 39 minutes of the
movie's total three-hour run time there
are plenty of moments in the
action-packed sequence for audiences to
focus on however there is one bit in
particular that not only adds to the
excitement but gets a big laugh from
viewers you may remember the escape in
the fellowship of the ring in which our
heroes run for their lives in the ruins
of moria at one point aragorn helped sam
get across a crumbling staircase by
throwing him through the air to be
caught by boromir on the other side
however gimli proudly refuses the
ranger's help firmly stating nobody
tosses a dwarf during the peak of the
helm's deep battle gimli and aragorn
make their way to a bridge overflowing
with enemy soldiers trying to break into
the fortress to get across the gap
between the bridge and the stairs at the
outer wall gimli reluctantly offers the
only solution under his breath he tells
aragorn that the ranger will have to
toss him across the gap to get to the
bridge
aragorn agrees although the dwarf first
makes him promise not to tell legolas he
does have his pride after all gimli's
stocky figure being thrown through the
air landing triumphantly and hacking
away at the orcs is not only an awesome
sight to see but a hilarious callback to
the first film's joke that's definitely
worth watching again
throughout the first two lord of the
rings films the hobbits mary and pippen
are rarely seen apart which made it all
the more shocking when the two were
separated in the third entry the return
of the king after pippin makes the
mistake of revealing himself to sauron
through the mystical palantir gandalf
takes him to ministerith the capital
city of gondor
there pippin swears himself into the
service of the city stuart denethor
though his hope is that he might make up
for his grave mistake by doing something
noble pippin finds that denethor is not
the ideal mentor a man filled with
bitterness over the loss of his son
boromir denethor would rather give into
despair than fight for the hope of
mankind
as soldiers of gondor go off to battle
denethor skulks in his grand hall with
pippen at his side the steward requests
that pippen sing a song for him and
though the hobbit is clearly not in the
mood for a lively tune he obliges as
pippin's voice echoes through the halls
we see the men of gondor ride into a
hopeless battle that will seal their
doom it's a truly haunting moment and
boyd's beautiful vocals are the perfect
addition to the scene
the song he sings is one of sorrow and
grief and it will never leave your head
sadly neither will the disturbing image
of denithor biting into a cherry tomato
though helm's deep is one of the most
memorable battle sequences in the lord
of the rings trilogy the battle of
pelanor fields from the return of the
king perhaps holds the most significance
it turns the tide of the war of the ring
and gives the good people of middle
earth the upper hand against sauron's
forces while there are plenty of
triumphant moments during this epic
battle there is one that stands out
above the rest
eowyn the shield maiden of rohan has
dealt with misogyny all of her life
while she is expected to be happy in her
gilded cage at theodin's court all she
ever wanted was to fight for the people
she loves she finally gets her chance
when she disguises herself in armor and
rides with the army along with her new
hobbit friend mary eowyn's time to shine
comes when she faces off against the
dreaded witch king on the battlefield as
the leader of the nazgul taunts that he
cannot be killed by any man eowyn
removes her helmet declaring
i am no man
she then offers the killing blow that
destroys the witch king once and for all
and gives fans one of the most
victorious moments in the trilogy
the return of the king features a
dramatic climax that culminates within
the perilous realm of mordor after
traversing the treacherous planes
escaping the clutches of orcs and
ascending the volcanic mount doom frodo
and sam find the completion of their
quest close at hand all of their
struggles and suffering will soon come
to a conclusion one way or the other as
they enter into the heart of mount doom
frodo hesitates at the edge of the fiery
abyss much to the horror of his loyal
companion and the audience frodo has a
sudden change of heart instead of
destroying the ring he decides to claim
it as his own placing it on his finger
and making himself invisible all seems
lost until the vengeful creature known
as gollum interferes determined to get
to the one ring gollum attacks the
invisible frodo and bites off the finger
wearing the ring as any lord of the
rings fan will tell you gollum
inadvertently becomes the hero of the
story at that moment back in the
fellowship of the ring it was gandalf
himself that predicted gollum would have
a big part to play tragically however
gollum meets his demise when he plummets
into the lava pit below still clinging
to his beloved treasure the vision of
gollum sinking into the fiery liquid
followed by the one ring is one that
will live forever in our minds
after the one ring is destroyed in the
return of the king the audience can
finally breathe a collective sigh of
relief sauron is defeated the remaining
fellowship has been reunited and all is
once again well in middle earth now it's
time for aragorn to finally take his
place as the rightful king of gondor the
coronation scene is one of both
celebration and solemnity everyone has
gathered to see the crowning of aragorn
their heroic leader and faithful friend
as the crowd of subjects bow and make
way for their new king aragorn reaches
the line of the four hobbits frodo sam
pippen and mary yet when the halflings
begin bowing to him aragorn protests
insisting
[Music]
the new king then kneels before them and
bows his head and the massive crowd
follows his example
the sight of so many kneeling before the
humble hobbits is enough to make anyone
gasp in awe as well as bring a tear to
your eye these four characters have come
a very long way from their simple life
in the shire
each of them has demonstrated his
bravery and resilience in the face of
impossible odds and came out forever
changed this relevant moment reminds us
of the most important theme of the lord
of the rings trilogy anyone no matter
their size or stature is capable of
doing great things
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you